good morning it's tuesday i was recently
asked to speak to a group of college
students and here is some of what i said
there's a certain strain of nihilism
that has grown popular of late
everything's trash so why even bother
nothing matters in the long run anyway
and i'm sympathetic to these
perspectives because the world is
profoundly unjust and our shared
challenges are overwhelming and also yes
i am aware that nothing matters in the
long run something like 275 million
stars are going to die tomorrow and in
that context it's a little difficult to
get excited about earthly affairs like
building bridges and sewer systems and
voting but i reject nihilism not only
because i believe that nihilism like all
straightforward answers to life's great
questions is inadequate but also because
i think human life itself is imbued with
meaning i wrote my book the anthropocene
reviewed because i wanted to pay
attention to where my attention was
going and by attention i don't mean like
the ability to focus without distraction
i mean consciousness itself our soul
stuff where that's going after all what
and who you care about what and who you
devote your soul stuff to when taken
together will be known as your life and
through three and a half years of
writing the book i learned some stuff
about like staphylococcus aureus and how
grocery stores came to exist but the
biggest thing i learned and it surprised
me is that i am broadly in favor of
humans now i want to be clear that as
species go we are a catastrophe we have
caused countless extinctions we've
poisoned rivers and caused famines and
murdered the innocent like we aren't the
first form of life to become so powerful
and ubiquitous that our very success
endangers the planet's climate and
biodiversity cyanobacteria caused a mass
extinction over a billion years ago but
we're the first species to know what
we're doing while we do it but then
there's the other side of the coin which
is that we are also really interesting
we know the structure of dna we make art
and other things like sports and
cappuccino and youtube that we don't
technically need to survive but still
kind of need we know what's keeping the
stars apart we try to protect our young
we make really good music now of course
none of this matters in the grand scheme
of things the sun is still going to turn
into a red giant and boil our oceans
away but we don't live in the grand
scheme of things i think there is
meaning in human life because there is
meaning in us and in how we are bound
together there is meaning in loving and
being loved and in hearing and being
heard like when i'm thinking about why
any of it matters i always think about
this line from richard wright i would
hurl words into this darkness wait for
an echo and if an echo sounded no matter
how faintly i would send other words to
march to fight to create a sense of the
hunger for life that gnaws in us all i
reject nihilism because i believe in the
value of hurling words into the darkness
not least because it is possible that
you when you are in the darkness may
echo them back i know that optimism at
the moment feels foolish and cringy and
nihilism feels like a way of trying to
cut yourself off from the reality of
feeling so you don't have to grapple
with all the complexities and pain i get
it i do it too but i would encourage you
to hurl your words into the darkness to
never give up on trying to bring light
and noise to where otherwise there would
only be cave darkness and silence
equally i would ask you to be an echo to
tell your friends and loved ones that
you hear them not just the words that
they're saying but also the feelings and
thoughts that lie beneath those words i
think the opportunity and responsibility
of personhood is to make meaning and to
acknowledge the meaning in others lives
we do this through loving and helping
others and through allowing others to
love and help us and through deepening
our shared understanding of the universe
and our place in it so yeah maybe
nothing matters but only until we make
things matter and maybe life is
meaningless but only until we make it
meaningful
hank i'll see you on friday